投資朋友歡迎收聽早晨財經速解讀,
現在是臺北時間2026年8月18號禮拜二,
早上8點31分,
大家早安我是頂浩,
每天早上開會前半小時,
我們在這邊陪伴著各位一起解讀國際財經新聞時事變化,
在昨天美伊60天的談判大限已經到了,
大家都忘了60天前曾經有這樣的一個談判時間限協議,
結果到期以後看起來美伊雙方的談判條件仍然無法到位,
這一次反而大家關注的是國際油價又漲了2%,
30年期國債殖利率已經衝高到19年以來的新高了
那當然啦
我們也知道股票市場好像對於債券市場的反應也不是特別大
照理來講
殖利率的顯數衝高應該會回過頭來壓抑一下股市
但股市似乎也沒怎麼回跌
只是停止上漲而已
當時美伊在6月份所簽署的諒解備忘錄
原本預估60天內就要停戰
那會有很多細節要做探討
比如說伊朗的核計劃
荷姆斯海峽的開放問題
或者海外的資產節動等等
結果川普表示
由於目前幾乎看不到
對於伊朗戰爭快速結束的可能性
所以很有可能是阿曼
在荷姆茲海峽談判過程當中
從中作梗
所以美軍即將發動進一步的轟炸
那就聽聽就好
但布蘭特原油價格
昨天已經正式突破了90美元
市場的壓力
我們就看看
什麼時候會從債券市場
回過頭來壓抑股票市場
至少現在股市
也不是說就因此而下跌
只是盤在這樣的一個區間
等待進一步的訊息
那事實上這一次的AI股重新接棒
大家會重新聚焦到
因為Enthropy預估可能在10月份就會上市了
市場上正在預估
吸納如此龐大的資金IPO
你要知道Enthropy現在的市值已經超過了1.5兆
基本上比OpenAI市值還要來得大
那資金量是否能夠成功的去吸取呢
值得觀察
但是各大指數的確在這一段的反彈當中
已經來到了一個瓶頸未捷
以道瓊指數來看
昨天下跌272點
0.51%
所以53459點
連續幾天開始回擋了
標普派指數下跌40點
0.52%
所以在7745點
它就盤在這樣的一個區間
好像碰到了一種結界一樣
幾乎就是180度水平的
納斯達克指數下跌84點
0.32%
所以在26644點
一樣開始進入到盤整區間
費辦反而昨天大漲203點
1.64%
所以12621點
如果是從技術線性角度來看
反而費辦的積極是偏低的
不過它還是今年漲最多的資產
現在有點類似
1940年希特勒著名的暫停命令
就是德軍裝甲部隊
停止向圍困的
敦克爾克的英法聯軍進攻
突然就停了
然後股市就盤在這樣的一個水位
標普納指道瓊都是如此
所以未來能不能創造一個
這個敦克爾克大策隊的歷史奇蹟值得觀察
不過就感覺好像碰到了某種結界
反而是記憶體股開始陸續做反彈
我們看昨天記憶體族群
梅光強漲了4.13%
威騰漲了5.3%
Sandyx漲了8.8%
希傑2%
SK海力士ADI有3.04%
陸續都已經突破了過去幾周的下行循環
那現在大家很明顯
有一點在等回檔的感覺
就是再漲高也不太願意追了
每個人都在等股票市場何時會有進一步的回擋
其實納斯達克100指數
這一輪其實下修相對比較堅挺一點
但他從第一點也反彈了接近10%
重新站上50日均線
而且他距離歷史新高也不遠
因為道瓊標普在上禮拜都已經先創高了
大家會觀察這一週納指是否有機會
能夠把追下行情
把行情給拉上去
不過市場上很明顯
保持在這樣的位階一天兩天
來到5天很明顯就有那種
等下一次回檔再買的意願
結果回檔就遲遲不來
所以納斯達克100指數
放在過去20年的週期來看
估值是偏高的
可是放在過去5年
它的基期由於股價並沒有產生暴漲
尤其在今年
所以它的本益比就慢慢慢慢的往下倒
韓國股市一週內也暴漲了13%
這一次你說是單純嘎空
再往上漲就不一定是嘎空了
就是資金慢慢重新歸來了
這也是很有意思的一點
因為如果是從韓國股市
目前去槓桿情形的話
來做觀察
會發現其實去化槓桿
還是蠻明顯的
但是在8月份
雖然去化槓桿資金
沒有說完全的加槓桿回來
可是整個8月份到目前為止
整個韓國股市的現貨性買盤
其實也是異常堅挺的
你看當時的韓股龍智育
從6月份的38.6兆韓元
一路降到7月底的33兆
那現在就算有回溫
大概也是34到35兆
說明散戶的追高資金早就已經撤離了
可是在韓股的現貨型買盤
尤其是針對整個COSP指數
整個8月份幾乎都在顯著的放大
總資產規模還在慢慢的拉伸
所以他只能說玩槓桿的人離開了
可是存股的人看起來從來沒有離開過
所以只能說本輪的槓桿ETF規模
進入到脊椎以後
他等同於把整個7月份視為一種去槓桿
但是市場上並沒有出現那種集體性
所有散戶同時出現的恐慌
所以大家還是要觀察
如果7月份不能夠把它當成一個
比較中期回調的普遍性恐慌
它只是一個上槓杆的這些投資人被迫離場
那也許今年還是有機會來做進一步的中期回調的
這個也是當然也是個人比較期待的
畢竟每次回調都越來越短
以前都想說你回調三個月
那如果真的要縮短
那回調一個月
多回調兩週的
很常這樣出現
那你說只回調兩週三週
那至少來個升V
結果每一次都是前V
那我個人是比較偏好升V
誰討厭升V呢
但是你發現很多指數
它基本上都是屬於前V
比如說像納指
像道瓊標普
你其實也沒有太多空間
除了少數晶片之外
所以這件事情也就說明
未來有沒有可能
整個大盤
再遭受新一波的估值賣壓呢
直立率預期
其實就很重要的觀察重點了
因為科技巨頭這一次為了蓋治療中心
買GPU和電力設備來借錢
已經開始跟美國政府
搶債券市場的資金了
美國政府一直髮債
所以他一直在吸納債券市場的投資未納量
結果美國投資等級債企業
今年已經發了1.5兆美元的公司債
年增幅大增了三成六
光是大型科技公司就借款借了2000億
所以你說他把投資等級債都不斷的發行
把資金全部給吸走
那美國政府的問題該怎麼解決呢
以前都是你們買我的債券
結果阿發貝現在30年期公債殖利率
大概是接近6.7%
比同期的美債高出了1.15個百分點
Meta的部分
最近已經殖利率已經上升到7.5%了
我這越發越高
你要說今年年底有碰到8到9%
搞不好都會遇到
如果更長天期的話
那就意味著市場上投資等級債
正在瘋狂的跟美國國債來搶購資金
那會不會形成利率預期的反壓
這是值得觀察的重點
另外一方面
全球的套利模式空間
也受到日元這一波
殖利率升息的影響而受到壓制
我們當然知道日元
到底能不能持續走深
這個還是要取決於
市場上針對國債壓力的變化
可是至少可以看到
美日之間即便有所聯手
仍然無法阻擋
十年期公債殖利率的持續創高
昨天又創下歷史新高了
應該講本世紀歷史新高
30年級殖利率已經衝高到4.07%了
不知道有沒有機會在未來幾年
我們看到日本國債的利率比美國高呢
如果按照這種升息態勢
搞不好未來5年到10年就可以看到了
30年級它都已經衝高到4.07%了
這個時候投資日本國債
居然可以有這麼大的一個回饋報酬
值得觀察
10年級的部分大概是在3%左右
那這件事情就意味著
接下來的借錢壓力會來得越來越大
尤其又有Entropy的IPO
所以市場進入到搶錢大作戰
事實上私人信貸
現在的壓力也蠻高的
我們根據美國20家上市
商業發展公司第二級
叫停止計息貸款
佔貸款成本中位數
已經上升到2.8%
這個比例是什麼呢
就是停止計息貸款
就是這個貸款代表借款的人
他已經停止付你利息了
那就是說他準備要違約了
他有可能後來會還你
不過至少他違約風險是偏高的
目前這個比例
大概已經上升了接近一倍
那私人信貸違約在7月份的比例
也創下歷史新高
所以這說明有些人
當時因為兩年前三年前
那個時候利率跟現在差很多
真的借了非常多的債
那現在利息升到這種水位
又是浮動利率
那乾脆就倒一倒算了
我也不願意付你這麼高的利息了
所以從資金流向來看
我們今天要從三個角度來看
一個是美國目前的資金流向
我們當然知道美國把龐大的資本
投入到AI和科技基金
那臺灣又把這一些
零組件私服器的投資
變成出口和現金流
中國則是面臨供應鏈轉移
和資本重新配置的壓力
所以就要看一下
全球的錢正在往哪裡走
這是我們今天要觀察的重點
首先看的是美國
美國的部分
因為我們知道
現在是財報季尾聲
我們就等輝達公佈財報
差不多就有一個圓滿了
那之前我們看到
Meta 微軟 阿發貝
亞馬遜 蘋果
接連公佈財報
其實營收和獲利
都是比市場預期還要來得高的
但當時市場出現了比較明顯的分化
主要原因就來自於
市場針對現金流預估的變化
以及當下情緒的演變
什麼意思呢
就是公佈財報的時候
剛剛好在去槓桿
所以通常是以負面解讀
不過回過頭來說
它似乎在自由現金流層面
仍然沒有那種很明顯的直觀聯繫
說你只要自由現金流是翻證的
股價就可以一直漲
翻覆的就得一直跌
它還是取決於市場給予你的
的護城和預期表現
那現在大家的觀察重點就來自於
重點是整個市場上
有沒有意識到這項風險
如果有的話
那其實沒有想象中來的大壓力
但如果市場上都沒有意識到
這個債券市場不斷的膨脹
所形成資金流的吸取壓力的話
那麼當然就會有所緊張
那現在好處是什麼呢
就是到處都是風險
這可能也是目前美股
不願意追高的主因
我們看Meta這一次跟貝萊德
在德州埃爾帕所清建的新一輪資料中心
總投資已經高達140億
但最大問題是什麼
最大問題是沒有保險公司想要幫你保
就是這座AI資料中心
現在保險市場不願意提供完整保證
它裡面有很多細節理賠
金融時報的報道是
最高理賠只願意投給你4.2億
我投資是140億
你最高理賠金額是4億
那有保跟沒保一樣
恐怖攻擊最多給你6億
一般責任險最多隻有5000萬美元
所以面對一個140億美元的專案
主要財產的保險額度只有4.5億
這說明著市場上很明顯
對於這項計劃承保人的意願
其實相對比較謹慎一點
那第二個角度
來自於我們過去所提到
市場上會更進一步關注
這一種CDS或者債券利差的險住升高
你必須要付出更多的風險益酬
所以才會導致過去一段時間
CDS價格的持續翻證
那當然我們後續要做進一步觀察
那就是這一輪到底最後
能不能如我們所預期的自由現金流
能夠順勢翻證解決本人的困境呢
現在你之所以會擔心
就是覺得他口袋沒錢了
而且會一直沒錢
所以債券市場壓力越來越大
債券市場把資金都吸走以後
股市就漲不動了
這是大概邏輯
可是我們真實所看到的概況是
他這樣子的利空消息
頂多也不過是中期回調的理由
仍然不是泡沫破滅的藉口
泡沫破滅一定要供給過剩
而現在根據高盛的預估
美國AI資料中心
最後有可能在2029年之前
第一波資料中心新建
大概是隻有70%到80%
能夠正式的新建完成
這是一個恰到好處的一個新建鏈
為什麼
全部完成
然後發現根本沒有那麼多的算力需求
那就算力過剩
這當然有風險
到底過兩年三年
我們的需求到底有沒有這麼多
這是一個觀察重點
或者到時候在物理世界
發現無法推進
那也是一個技術風險
可是另外一方面
如果你一定確保在2029年
幾乎完全蓋不夠
而且電力設施
按照目前的預估
完全跟不上的話
那就是會有部分的資料中心
新建完成
然後會有部分的自由線金流
開始翻證
但是有部分的還沒有蓋完
所以就變成了
它沒有立即泡沫撲面的風險
因為它不會算力過剩
可是它也蓋了不少的資料中心
最後這些資料中心一運營
當他蓋完的那一刻
錢就開始回收了
所以我認為
我還是比較樂觀的預估
在明年年底到後年年初
超大型雲端自由的現金流
就會翻陣
到時候財報就變成
高強度互利成長
並且高自由現金流
這個是我比較大談的一個預估
我相信這些巨頭
他總有辦法把錢給收回來
只要蓋完
他現在就是因為沒蓋完
所以蓋不到
現在就是一個提前佈局的重要性
投資也是如此
真正有價值的佈局
都不是等到時候
錢投出去都已經收回來了
然後大家才意識到
那是多頭
那我可以買股票
那都得多晚了
晶片越多
你就需要越多的資料中心
資料中心越多
需要更多的電
電不夠就需要天然氣核能
當所有人都意識到這件事情
開始在旁邊
配置一個家電站
這個時候
你才可以瞭解說
提前佈局的重要性
你說一定要等到
他們蓋完錢拿到
你才決定
我相信AI行情
我要買股票了
我相信到時候點位
你大概也買不下去
所以提前佈局
我認為還是打贏本場大戰的重要關鍵
也是沒有任何一家巨頭
願意放棄在這個時間點
增加資本支出的根本原因
有些人都清楚知道
提前佈局才是影響到
接下來打勝這場大戰的關鍵
你像Kobe
Kobe怎麼樣
他永遠都是凌晨三點
在洛杉磯練球
村上春樹大家知道
永遠都是凌晨三點
提前起床寫稿
庫克永遠都是凌晨三點起來先運動
馬斯克經常凌晨三點提前起床
在工廠處理產線問題
只有你凌晨三點起來吃牛肉麵
還不自己煮
所以真正拉開距離的
往往並不是比別人更會追
你只要比別人更早準備
這些巨頭大家都有時候會嘲諷
投那麼多錢收得回來嗎
他之所以現在自由心情有反覆
就是因為他還沒蓋完
他一旦蓋成
我相信錢進來的速度
會比想象中還要來得快
這些方向
你要知道資料中心的缺電
記憶體的漲價
有時候你落後一拍
你發現你就已經錯失過行情了
你等記憶體漲價
你才來研究記憶體
等合約價漲價
你才開始研究股票
等資料中心告訴你缺電
你才開始研究重點股
那不是永遠都慢一拍嗎
本來就是有這樣的一個提前作為
這給投資朋友做的一些觀察和思維
當然我們回過頭說
市場上現在就會有不同的一個操作邏輯
像是美銀的哈奈特
他過去的確有提醒過
今年可能在中旬左右
會有一個比較大的中期回調風險
那針對下半年
他一樣跟我看法差不多
屬於中期回調的再次展現
原因很簡單
第一是美國國債
現在已經突破40兆美元
在未來的速度
可能在29年會突破50兆
這麼快的利息支出的上升
會導致長天期國債殖利率
上行速度加快
最近美國30年提供債殖利率
也飆受到5.126%
這也是本世紀以來的新高
所以AI投資熱潮
也讓這項問題持續的雪上加霜
企業債的供給年增幅高達61%
剛才提到光是這幾家巨頭
它的融資規模今年已經2600億了
把錢全部給搶光了
所以他認為始終會形成股價的估值回調
可是重點是估值回調
不是泡沫破滅
所以他現在把投資濃縮成四個縮寫
一個叫ABB
Anything But Bond
避開債券就好
你什麼都可以投
看好電力
看好什麼
先避開債券
為什麼
因為市場上的借貸量還是很高
你不確定它會市場沉壓多久
這個叫做ABC
Anywhere but China
你什麼都可以投
但你要避開中國
他的看法
其實也有他後面的道理
他認為很明顯
你可能買到中國市場
即便他最後能夠勝出
他的利潤率不一定表現特別好
從過去在太陽能
在面板的經驗是如此
他有可能成為贏家
但他通常成為贏家的那一刻
他的利潤都不是特別的好看
第三叫做ABD
叫Anything But Dollar
就什麼都可以
你要避開美元
因為這個是川普政策
在過去一貫的立場
基本上是保持的相對弱勢美元
最後叫做AI
All in AI 全壓AI
所以它的方向其實還是有所明顯態勢
避開債券 避開中國
避開美元 全壓AI
大概是現在的邏輯
當然投資做久就會發現
真正拉開距離的並不是誰知道的最多訊息
誰是預測的最準
是誰能夠把一套正確的方法練成習慣
新手有時候看到機會就很急著出手
行情一動就想追
風險出現你又急著跑
經驗越多你反而要知道
稍微先觀察先判斷
先確認自己承受的風險是多少
然後等到指標到了
你覺得差不多了就決定採取行動
成熟的投資
不是每一次都可以幫助你買在最低
賣在最高
讓你知道什麼時候該踩油門
什麼時候該踩剎車
其實就可以了
我們常講說
怎麼看出一個人開車的
那個水平的高低
第一是什麼
就是能夠快速的找到車鑰匙的空
就老司機
他可以在黑暗當中
直接就把鑰匙插進去
那新司機你那摸半天
你還找不到空
那第二就是觀察
新司機通常
新車都迫不及待的
就想要上車
然後立馬就啟動
然後想要開車
老司機都會先環繞一週
觀察一下車
感受一下質感
才讓車跑起來更加絲滑
最後就是後續的保養
清洗
尤其是車的大燈
還有車屁股
因為有時候會有蚊子
灰塵沾到
所以時常清洗很重要
對 我講的是投資
所以投資很重要的一點
就是你要能夠了解說
你原本所設計的初衷
原本所設定的原則
你最後能不能套用在
每一次的
不管是怪力修正
終極回調
你先有了立場以後
你再來做你的投資
而並不是根據每天的訊息來做改變
這給大家做的一些省思
好 那我們回往下看
看一下臺北股市的變化
臺股剛才我們講到
現金流的來源
其實來自於晶片股的獲利營收
這一波臺股的創高
它不是單純資金行情
跟美國這種
由資金需求鏈所帶動的信貸擴展
又不太一樣
美國人是在瘋狂的借錢
來蓋一個還沒有確切營收
大幅回饋的資料中心
臺灣是一直賣資料中心裡頭的
GPU和伺服器
所以錢真的進來了
整個26年第二季上市櫃公司
稅後存益已經突破了2兆元
來到2.08兆
季征服是33%
年征服高達172%
累計上半年3.65兆
這麼龐大的一個資金規模
從哪裡來的
主要都是從美國來的
美國現在在AI伺服器相關的貿易逆差
已經高達4000億美元了
這是兩年前的三倍
臺灣人現在真的在暴賺美國人的錢
那現在好處是什麼呢
好處是臺灣的傳產也開始陸續復甦了
我們舉例來說
你像臺碩世寶
全年獲利
這次法輪預估可以來到2380億
到2400億左右
以前我們知道
世寶的確受到市場承壓很長一段時間
今年一方面是傳產景氣的復甦
另外一方面是
美醫戰士稍微把油價給拉起來了
另外一方面
這些巨頭
這些世寶
在AI電子材料成長
也開始有明顯的爆發
這也是為什麼
今年是有機會可以挑戰EPS的歷史高峰
這是值得觀察重點
當然了
股價的波動
這個每天行情當然會有炒作的疑慮
可是至少可以看到它的本業在哪裡
航運股也是
航運股最近運價連三漲
外資又回補
長龍目標價陸續做調升
原因也很簡單
當然是馬斯基在全球航運開始帶頭衝
另外一方面
背後還是有一些供給的稀缺原因
一個是墨西哥
最近想要打造路上的巴拿馬運河
為什麼
因為馬拉瑪運河現在受到乾旱影響
部分船隻本來要等三天的
現在等三週才過得了
整個航班大亂
另外一個就是歐洲
歐洲現在因為屬於乾旱期又很熱
西歐6月7月本來都是最熱的時期
那現在由於氣候問題的原因
萊茵河關鍵水位
已經跌到有史記錄以來的最低
之前多瑙河也是
多瑙河水低到連德軍以前的艦艇
二戰的艦艇
還有一些甚至不管是羅馬帝國
一些古老的遺蹟都露出來了
就水這麼低
百年一建
就發現市場上
針對傳統的運量
都產生進一步的稀缺
所以導致運價的顯著攀升
有利於航運股資金的一個拉抬
所以不管怎麼說
你看到傳產似乎也開始動起來了
那最後所造成的結果就是
臺股內部的超額出序快速暴增
23年臺灣的超額出序
就出口減進口也不過三兆
25年是5.6
今年已經8.4兆了
明年搞不好就突破11兆了
2020年5年前
我們的人均GDP也不過2.8萬塊
今年我們已經突破4萬了
等到明年年底搞不好就5萬了
按照目前主技術的預估
看起來明年年底到後年年初
臺灣人均GDP
莫名其妙
5年內就真的要完全翻倍了
來到5萬
那等同於人均GDP是150萬臺幣
那一樣
我們講的是
不一定是你的薪資150萬
可是你老闆平均一個員工
他可以貢獻150萬的產值
所以為什麼現在這麼缺工
因為人實在是太昂貴了
人的產值非常非常的高
這個現象
你看超額儲蓄和超額儲蓄率
它是同步創高
不是大家把錢都拿去炒股了
是錢太多
被迫要挪一點資金到股票市場
因為超額儲蓄率也在瘋狂的上升
從15.8%
5年前到現在預估是28%到29%
他不是把錢拿去炒股而已
是定存太多了
只好節一點定存
做一些股市配置
這才是根本原因
他並不是存量轉移
是整個增量市場
那句話怎麼講的
我知道你們還有錢
這是一個真實現象
如果你生在臺灣
你發現你每天接觸的是出口
突破兆元
超額儲蓄這種數據
國民儲蓄率超過20兆元
你看到這些數據
你會發現很現實的結構
就是錢真的一直在進來
而且多到實體國內的投資
都未必吸收的完
現在最大問題是什麼
兩年三年以後
臺灣政府最大的問題
絕對不是沒有錢的問題
兩年後是11兆的超額儲蓄
要去哪裡
要去海外投資嗎
要留到股市嗎
要留到房市
再漲一輪房價嗎
還是轉化成新的產業投資
臺灣有這麼多東西可以投資嗎
臺灣投資又那麼小
這麼龐大的一個資金量
你錢要去哪裡呢
這是政府未來的挑戰
那你說未來有沒有錢
那根本就不是政府挑戰
你已經知道他多有錢了
所以這個就是我們看到
你身邊的一個吸收的資訊
會影響到你對於臺灣的宏觀視角
我們以前常講說
你的財富通常是
你身邊五個朋友的平均值
你每天就接觸這些資訊
你未給大腦什麼
大腦最後就會用這套世界
來替你做決定
這麼多年我們都是看這些數據
來幫助我們做決定
比如說體感溫度有沒有落差
老闆怎麼可能給我薪資150萬
當然是如此
體感溫度每個人不一樣
我們當然知道貧富差距的問題
可是你要客觀公允的看待臺灣經濟
這些數據
我相信它也不是這個月才公佈
它每個月都公佈
陸續公佈以後
你大概就可以瞭解真實的環境
你的財富就是你最常接觸的
五個YouTube頻道的平均值
五個朋友的平均值
真正要講的
其實不是朋友多少錢
是環境會影響你
什麼叫做正常的投資觀念
如果你身邊討論的
買什麼去哪裡玩
如何分歧
那你當然會把收入拿去做提高消費
那你身邊的人都是談投資
現金流 創業 宏觀資金
那你發現生活的一部分
你就有方式可以把自己的投資績效
拉得更高
所以你長時間花在什麼樣的資訊
最後就會形成那個環境當中的平均值
負面的也是一樣
如果你一群同事每天都在抱怨公司
久了你還沒離職
心態搞不好已經先離職了
那一群人如果
天天都在刷卡分期
貸款買名牌
那你就覺得
這是現代人的正常生活
月光是很正常的
月光不是很正常
現在超額出去這麼多
大家手上都是一堆錢
月光是不正常的
一群男人
禮拜一清晨到機場飛去越南
那能幹什麼正經事
所以環境會影響你
難道吃個河粉聊聊天嗎
不可能
所以你身邊的人
他最後就會影響到
你未來的投資環境
生活環境這是很重要的
所以吸收對的財經資訊是很重要的
好那結論是什麼
結論就是上半年的稅收
目前看起來已經暴增80%了
今年上半年全臺灣稅收
已經來到2兆5876億
這是歷史新高
尤其成長速度最快的
那肯定是正交稅
成長了188%
這很神奇
現在一兆以下都叫量縮
那當然在這樣的一個效果底下
等同於中央稅客收入預算案
整體稅收數今年一定是創高的
那某種程度就說明著一定超增
超增比較非正規用詞
叫做收入達成率超過百分之百
目前是中央和地方已經全數達標
光是半年的一個增長
幾乎都不用預測下半年有多少了
只要下半年跟去年一模一樣
基本上臺灣的稅收今年一定超過百分之百
甚至中央政府已經衝高到136%
這也是為什麼昨天賴總統正式宣佈
又普發了
這次是增列2357億
在維持收支平衡不變的情況底下
基本上一定是維持的
因為現在已經超增了
27年每人會普發現金1萬塊
這一次政府是把普發現金
定調成AI紅利全民共享
說很大一部分的成長都來自於AI
現在回饋給稅收和經濟紅利的重新分配
這也說明著
有時候全民普發
我們要開始把它視為一個新常態政策
每年就是會多出這麼個1萬塊2萬塊
發到你的口袋當中
另外一方面
當然也就意味著
內部的補貼速度會來得越來越快
其實地方政府現在補貼也很兇
全臺灣已經有超過30個鄉鎮市
在今年進入到普發現金的行列
佔所有基層公所超過一成
有些地方一次發5000
6000甚至更多
表面上六都以外的198個鄉鎮
目前沒有法定債務
但也不代表財政真的很健全
所以中央是真的有錢
但是地方發這麼多錢
你要知道鄉鎮自籌財源比例
已經從最近三年30%下降到27%了
所以一方面你越來越依賴中央
縣市的補助
一方面你又拿現金
然後跟選民來做發放
大家現在已經普發現金
變成一種新常態了
我舉個比較標準的
像嘉義
嘉義18個鄉鎮市
一年內已經有12個普發現金了
金額有發2000的
也有發到6000的
人口最多的是民雄
相關一次發2000元
就花掉了1.3億
其他有像之前有丹納斯颱風
以災後紓困為理由
那也有說你發我也得發那種福利競爭
所以到處都在發
你看嘉義縣政府
現在已經負債35.8億了
到處都在發
所以你可以觀察到一個失之現象
就這種經濟的高強度發展
有時候政府也是
也不知道該怎麼做
能夠削減這種貧富差距的
短期內的快速擴大
那現在最直接的
與其搞什麼補貼
搞什麼預因政策
先趕快讓你最勇敢
你先趕快拿到錢
錢趕快拿走
所以這也是我們看到
臺灣稅收的一個大變化
事實上臺灣的稅收結構
一直以來都有比較鮮明的特點
就是比較高度偏向直接稅
2025年直接稅比重是70.8
不只是首次突破7成
也明顯比日本 韓國 英國 法國
主要經濟體來得高
那從租稅理論來看
直接稅無法轉嫁
政府可以直接針對所得稅
和利潤來課稅
有利於調節收入的分配
所以達成租稅公平
但同時納稅人的感受會比較直接
痛苦感比較高
那現在就藉由
另外一部分普發現金的方式
降低這種痛苦感
那當然
很多人對於直接稅
或者間接稅的看法
本來就不太一樣
各自有偏好
那有些人問我說
那我偏好直接稅還是間接稅
我比較偏好直接稅
因為我都比較直接
我連牛肉麵都不用煮
不是
那所以我們觀察到的實質現象
就是現在整個臺灣的經濟的一個爆發
資金流的一個流入
它背後的資金流原理
跟我們看到美國藉由信貸擴增
所造成的資產膨脹
其實又不是同一個邏輯
因為時間因素
我們今天就稍微不聊
中國的資金流
明天繼續聊
可是今天要觀察的重點是什麼
就是如果我們把美國
臺灣
中國
放在同一份的資金流上面來看
現在最值得注意的
不是說今天哪個市場
漲哪個資金跌
而是說全球資本
正在重新選擇
它願意長期停留的方向
美國的優勢就是
它一直吸資金
讓你相信它能夠造夢
所以最後這些錢變成了實體的資料中心
臺灣則是靠資料中心當中的零組件
伺服器換取了龐大的外匯收入
那現在問題就是臺灣錢很多
油資亂氾濫
可是美國缺錢
快要沒錢蓋資料中心了
Entropy還要IPO
那最後所形成的邏輯會是什麼呢
我想很明顯的
那就是臺灣人對於美國市場的投資只會加大
不只是初級市場產業投資
市集市場一定會有越來越多的臺灣人
意識到臺灣沒有太多可以投資的環境
本益比也稍微越來越高了
最後只能讓臺灣人
就像當年的日本人一樣
我們一起去進攻紐約
這是最後的一個結論
這給投資朋友多些思考
臺股小漲44點
收在45905點
今天稍微開一點玩笑
每天都開
這年頭大家開玩笑
還是要掌握一下尺度
最好還是不要針對個人
如果要還是要弄公允或者社會事件
比如說你對身邊的親人
同事老闆
其實現在因為環境不一樣
還是儘量不要開
每個人接受程度不同
最好是嘲諷開不特定人的玩笑
比如說嘲諷整個大環境體制
比如說你開開政府的玩笑
我們政府真有錢
還是有點危險
還是不要好了
或者你可以嘲諷整個制度
生活環境等等
人心到長這樣
交通局幹什麼的
市長幹什麼吃
還是不要好了
好像也有風險
或者你可以開開
那種以前那種性別
男女的刻板印象
女孩子比較愛美
男孩子就是下半生思考
也不一定
那女孩子也有中心的
那還是不要亂開好了
不要亂開
看男生玩笑OK
這沒問題
你說浩哥
我們也會被冒犯的
我們也會不舒服
那又怎樣
沒人在乎
Nobody care
所以結論就是
可以繼續開男生玩笑
那其他都不要開
好不好
好 就零四分
今天結論是這樣子
我們把整個宏觀的資金量
稍微梳理一下
從美國到臺灣
那中國的部分
我們就稍晚兩天來做細節追蹤
但你可以觀察得出來
一個是油資過剩
一個是缺錢缺到有點慌
殖利率預期
不斷地往上拉抬效果
最終能夠解決這個問題的方式
是誰呢
就是賺最多錢的那個
這個趕快把錢投回去吧
這也是未來幾個月
我們相信很快會發生的事實
給投資朋友做一些思考
如果喜歡我們的節目
記得幫我們訂閱按贊加分享
我們就明天早上八點半
早晨財經四點多
再相見
祝各位投資朋友
看盤順利
操盤愉快